we must still unthrown her my point the
great love story aside she may sit on
your face but not on your throne
it was a joke you will see a lot of
different characters who you didn't see
interact together on season one
we've got a great ensemble of actors who
bring so much to the table
you get to see the characters that you
enjoyed in the first season
developing in really fun ways
this is great
we're his new best friend exactly am i
gonna be everything gregor wants to hear
what is it [ __ ]
mario's katherine's cynical voice of
reason i'm quite honest with her you
betrayed me saved betrayed are you alive
catherine still kind of holds that over
her a bit would you like some mario so
you do remember my name of course
mariel and grigor have this fantastic
relationship in season two um that's
very exciting what are you doing
changing the world mariel and catherine
are both hungry for power and we are
using each other she is stubborn yes but
she is also brilliant i hold out my hand
in friendship i do not want to close it
into a fist
archie gets visions from god by taking
magic mushrooms in the woods did you see
him i saw shining light they didn't have
such a great start
he's the traditionalist he wants to keep
things exactly the way they are so that
puts him in opposition to catherine you
are a german devil who has stolen our
country and is intent on burning russia
to the ground archie be on the right
side
georgina really admires catherine i've
always felt a strong connection with you
we have had sex which i did not enjoy
much she is in this really unusual
relationship with both peter and her
husband wiggle
you summoned me
it's an interesting little love triangle
i suppose gregor is peter's best friend
and confident you need to shut up
i'm worried his love for catherine as a
break on our plans i do not love her
huzzah wriggle's probably one of the few
people in the court who peter can really
be himself and show his weakness
seems a bit strong she came to me
unbidden you must make her believe there
is more to you than there is
elizabeth is really interesting because
on one hand she's a bit of a political
player
but she's also a bit of a bohemian
you can put a crown on a donkey it is
still a donkey she realizes that
katherine i think has amazing attributes
that would make her a brilliant leader
the joy of being a woman is knowing that
we have unseen and unacknowledged depths
and strengths beyond anything a man will
ever know
all right of course
sorry
developmental is still fairly
old-fashioned in my thoughts about
whether a woman and a young woman can
actually lead ice already battle plans
what is wrong with you
the general readies war plans it's sort
of the job there's a sort of journey to
go on with her where i gradually believe
in her it's a war hauler i take it
personally she dies he comes back
catherine and olo
together they'll bring the best out of
one another making russia great again in
one moment 58 million people are freed
steps
a mile is made in steps i teach
catherine how to play the game here at
the palace head not heart catherine
reason not rage
and catherine teaches orlo to
live dangerously be fearless and take
some big risks i had sex last night with
a woman
cute i like that you're fitting all
these different characters together that
might not quite fit i think from that
comes really exciting ideas
hazard
[Music]
you